yeah exactly i'm curious obviously you
mentioned that you were very passionate
about it from a young age
um but obviously when you're not in
school before that there's only
so many ways you can i guess practice or
get experience and what did you do
before that
practice because i was just doing it
from my bedroom oh
it's like a shitty microphone i was like
yeah yeah so like i
i bought like a really that shitty
microphone
and then um you know at home i'll be
recording my own voice and like
hearing it again and then recording it
again and you know because like now like
voice acting you have to be able to like
sing well as well
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what like
um you have to say i'm [ __ ] yeah like
you have to like dance as well right
so like voice voice actresses especially
yeah voice actors and actresses at this
day and age are basically idols wow it's
like totally different in like the west
yeah yeah like you know you have to like
like your own magazines like you have to
look good
like you know like visually well i guess
that's what like again it's so
the competition is so intense yeah yeah
like you said they're more idols but
you're they're always on tv right yeah
and so
yeah like you know in australia they
don't have much karaokes
no like yeah and so um there was one
really like crappy but it was the
closest thing we got to like the
japanese
style because like karaoke in australia
is a lot like in america where it's like
all open-minded yeah
yeah that's not good that's always been
weird to me that's not karaoke
god awful starts because i'm like that
guy's great that guy went up there
knowing he'd watch you this song but
no but like what if the opposite happens
right what if like the person before you
sings
like [ __ ] amazingly and then you're
like oh [ __ ] i have to go up and do sexy
back yeah
let me let me go let me go like if i'm
going to embarrass myself i just at
least i can just embarrass
myself in front of my friends yeah right
yeah yeah that's that's the way i think
about it
um yeah that's what that's why like the
concept of going to karaoke sober
is just non-existent in western
countries right because you're not going
to go out
up and sing on stage in front of
strangers if you're not intoxicated
unless you're just an amazing singer
here too so what so you you had to learn
how to sing as well or
you already sung well i i i practiced
singing from my bedroom
yeah yeah but that was really
embarrassing because um because my
parents were against me
doing voice acting right stop singing
they'll be kind of like oh yeah you can
go sing in your room but obviously
because it's not like soundproof or
anything
like i'm like my really bad singing is
like
like resonating throughout the whole
like house so like
you're practicing dancing as well when
you were like teenager no
like uh i didn't really practice dancing
because i was more into like
singing and acting right but yeah i'm
not much for dancing myself either
it's
so with the voice acting school did they
teach you any of these other aspects of
being a voice actress or was it just
purely the voice part
uh the school that i went to was like
just purely voice acting
but i know like um some schools teach
you singing and um
dancing as well especially like you know
how like i said that there was like
schools where you have to go like five
times a week yeah
yeah those are five times like eight
hours a day or like i'm not really
sure but um i assume not like you have
to live somewhere i think i when i
watched a video about it it was
something like they just go in the
evening after their job
like a lot of people do that in japan i
think that's normal that sounds about
right yeah there's like a lot of
different like
you know it always depends on the truth
you know but um
yeah so some school's teaching so what
type of voice sighting were you doing in
your bedroom when you were like 15 60.
um well i was kind of like copying
characters
okay you know like i feel it always
starts with like impersonating
yeah yeah yeah yeah and stuff yeah yeah
who did you impersonate
i i impersonated a lot um
wait um let me just think who did you
impersonate other than the obvious ones
league of legend characters yeah
do you know how i know that because
that's what he sent in for my audition
real there you go
league of legends legends characters
audition real oh my god
i don't know i just copied everything i
don't and i would do weird stuff for
people who wanted
free you know because someone has to
voice out these terrible stuff online
yeah
yeah yeah like sims projects and stuff
people just make sims animations oh
see and i would just have to do the
voice i hated it but i was like well i
just i want a voice act but i don't like
the project 50 bucks is 50 bucks right
yeah
are you gonna get paid are you kidding
me no no i was using a like a
headset microphone it sounded like
until you can buy a good microphone and
then you're like google how do i remove
static loud static how to remove
yeah your dusty
noise cancelling functions